I have just been diagnosed with great one breast cancer can sugar in your body promote cancer or isn't just estrogen driven.
So remember estrogen doesn't drive the cancer even though I think I just use that terminology and another question.
Estrogen with estrogen receptor positive breast cancers or other cancers any estrogen receptor positive cancer.
Estrogen isn't driving the cancer but that's 16 hydroxy esterone is
attaching to the estrogen beta receptors and that is blocking apoptosis. That's what that means.
So when you have a horrible positive cancer that means a hormone is attaching to a receptor on the cell
membrane of the cancer cell which is an apoptotic receptor.
So back to what is apoptosis it's the normal breakdown of a cell you want a cancer cell to go
through apoptosis but when it's being blocked then it doesn't die and it continues to replicate.
That's a bad thing. So there's multiple pathways of apoptosis. There's an intrinsic pathway that's
generated by the interior part of the cell and there's an extrinsic pathway of apoptosis that's
generated by these receptors. So when estrogen is blocking that receptor that it's blocking the normal
program death of that cell and it keeps the cell alive and therefore the cell can continue to replicate
and the cancer can continue to grow. So it's not really driving the cancer but it's blocking apoptosis
so in that sense I guess it is driving the cancer but the cancer has to be fueled from something so
that's a totally different thing. It's either being fueled by sugar glucose or it's being fueled by
iron or it's being fueled by amino acids and once you cut off the fuel source it will really help
looks cancer not to be able to continue to replicate but cancer smart so cells are smart they're
just trying to stay alive and trying to replicate though the DNA has damaged them in a replicated way
too quickly that's what cancer is. They will look they will look for a new fuel source so that's why you
might need to be tweaking and changing your diet throughout your care. So yes sugar in your body
can promote cancer by you by it being a fuel source. Estrogen yes can promote cancer by it blocking
the receptors on the cell membranes of the cancer cells therefore blocking the extrinsic pathway of apoptosis.